[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we're
going to be analyzing the
high-definition version of the code
geass sequel PV as you might remember
this PV was first leaked online back in
December of last year after it was aired
at the Code Geass special anniversary
event in November however the version
that was leaked online was very poor
quality so it was hard to tell all the
details that were actually in the PV
after the Code Geass special anniversary
blu-ray package was released in Japan on
April 21st the high-definition version
of the PV was finally leaked online
yesterday and now we're going to be
looking at all of the details that we
might have missed in the low quality PV
and analyzing them in this video
unfortunately I will not be able to
display the PV here for you on YouTube
because vonda Entertainment has been
taking down every single video that's
been posting it however I will leave a
link in the description to a third-party
website that I have nothing to do with
that has posted it so you can go and
watch it there in full HD I want to give
a huge thank you for all of you who
informed me about this on our discord
and in the comments to our YouTube
videos and special thank you to octoroo
who was the first to find this and
inform me about it on the discord server
itit was recently promoted to a night of
the round on our discord server which is
what we call our moderators so
congratulations out to do it is well
deserved and all your help is much
appreciated and of course if you want to
chat with us on a daily basis discuss
breaking news and be the first to know
when a new video is coming out you can
join our discord server as well the link
is in the description now I assume that
most of you have already seen the lower
quality version of the PV that came out
a few months ago and as I said now you
can watch the higher quality link in the
description for this video in order to
avoid copyright issues and getting this
video taken down I'm going to be only
looking at stills from the PV and
close-ups of the things that I find the
most interesting of the things that we
couldn't quite tell for sure from the
lower quality PV and analyzing them of
course if you feel that I missed
something let me know in the comments
I'd love to hear your take in terms of
the most interesting details that I see
now with the higher quality PV we can
see in the scene
we're two riders are riding camels in
the sand in beside what looks like an
ancient temple with the higher quality
if we zoom in we see that this person
this first person could definitely be c2
now some people were saying this before
as well
but when we look at it now with higher
quality it definitely looks like a woman
with long green hair now the picture is
not that clear it is not up close enough
to be 100% sure but judging by the
clothes the white clothes that c2 likes
and the seemingly green hair this could
definitely be c2 behind her we don't
know who it is it's not clear to make
out but of course many people will guess
if it's c2 then it must be Lelouch right
behind her we can't know for sure but it
is very possible we also see a tipped
over cart of course in this sequence in
the scene some people have been
speculating that maybe that is the cart
from the final scene of Code Geass where
we see c2 in the cart and people are
assuming of course that Lelouch was
driving the cart
however I don't know how that cart would
end up here in the middle of nowhere in
the sand but I guess it's possible we'll
have to wait and find out another really
interesting detail is the scene where we
see Jeremiah among a whole bunch of
flamingoes in the water if we zoom in we
can now tell for sure that right beside
Jeremiah among the flamingos Anya is
also there now the very next sequence
after this Flamingo scene in the PV is
jeremiah being seemingly attacked
shocked by electricity and he is dressed
the same way and he also appears to be
outside leading us to speculate that he
could be attacked in this very scene of
course we can be sure who is actually
attacking orange but the fact that Anya
is here could lead us to speculate that
perhaps she turned on him for some
reason
could it be that Mariana is not really
dead and that she possessed her again
couldn't be that she betrayed them for
some other reason could it be that it's
just a completely different villain and
Anya being there is a coincidence we
don't know but I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this in the comments the
next interesting detail is the airport
scene where now when you zoom in we can
tell pretty much for sure that the three
people at the bottom at the airport are
Nina Millie and rebel rumors have been
going around for a while now that it was
them three in this scene but with the
low quality P V it was really in
possible to tell for sure however this
to me looks like pretty conclusive
evidence in this scene where Cornelia is
walking up to an ancient temple we can
see an ancient statue and a sword buried
in the ground we also see what appears
to be some sort of modern research team
doing some type of research at the
temple and then the very next thing that
happens in the PV is an explosion that
Cornelia witnesses again this is very
interesting that the research team
caused the explosion that someone
attacked the research team what are they
researching in the first place is that
the origins of Geass this is really
interesting to me I'm really curious
about this and I'd love to hear what you
think as well the next thing we see is
some sort of landscape beside a river
and then we jump to Suzaku apparently
jumping for his life from some sort of
high-speed railway wagon but check out
what all around Suzaku it's orange trees
just like the orange trees in the final
scenes of Code Geass r2 where orange and
Anya were working on an orange farm now
in one of my previous videos where I
talked about an image from 2009 that
appears to show a scene from Code Geass
season 3 and by the way the link to that
video is in the description I mentioned
that Lelouch and c2 are shown to be in a
landscape with a lot of sheep and I
speculated that this could be in an area
of southwestern Australia known as the
area around the Murray River and I had a
bunch of reasons for this I talked about
it in that video of course we know that
Australia is a great place to run away
in the world of Code Geass because it is
not aligned with anyone Mao wanted to
escape there back when he was trying to
escape with c2 so of course it's a great
place to run and just look at this just
look at this sequence remember the
sequence with the river right before we
jump to Suzaku running for his life
around all the orange trees check this
out and compare this with these images
of the actual murray river area of south
western australia now i know everyone
keeps saying that i'm an Australia
conspiracy theorist because I keep
claiming that Australia is going to play
a role in code geass season 3 but I mean
look at these images I feel like they
might very well be in Australia the
orange farm might be
Australia guys let me know if you agree
with me let me know what you think I'd
love to hear from you down below also if
you are new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
because here at anime uproar we will
keep you up to date for all the latest
news and updates for code geass season 3
and a whole bunch of other anime and
once again if you want to chat with us
on a daily basis and be the first to
know when a new video is coming out you
can join the discord server link in the
description as always thank you so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]